Cheshire pulls a Beyonce and drops
another surprise video on us plus the
snubs and surprises from this year's
Emmy nominations and Beyonce spotted for
the first time since giving birth to the
twins to the live dammit it's a miracle
hey friends this is the daily denne I'm
Danny direct oh and yes Beyonce has
escaped her bunker and by bunker I mean
her Los Angeles area mansion where she's
been cooped up who's giving birth to the
twins Queen Bee was snapped arriving to
dinner at popular hotspot Nobu in Malibu
California on Wednesday with jay-z the
first time we've seen her since the
babies arrived last month now according
to an eyewitness the couple arrived at 8
p.m. in separate cars and was surrounded
by ten security guards she is so
untouchable even her husband has to take
a different vehicle to dinner this is
all after jay-z got super candid about
their marriage and what he called a
footnote to his confessional album 444
he admitted their relationship was not
built in the 100% truth and they had to
tear it down and start from the
beginning well rules are rules and there
will be no kissing on the first date you
hear me young man and have her home by
midnight all right now someone taking a
page from Beyonce's book of female
empowerment Ke$ha announced you recall
she already slayed me when she released
playing was the first single off her
upcoming album rainbow her first full
record in four years
well guys she done did it again she
dropped another one this time rendering
me almost speechless because the song
titled woman is so dope and features the
dap-kings horn piccola
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah oh the streamers of back-testing
back with another banger can we please
recut the Wonder Woman trailer to the
song apparently when you are forced to
go away for four plus years it comes
back with the fire speaking of Taylor
Swift had also come out of hiding for a
sec as well she returned to Instagram to
sing praises for bestie Selena Gomez and
her new single fetish Taylor shared the
song's cover art and captioned it sultry
pop magic from this dreamy almost
birthday girl now Taylor's self-imposed
silence is reportedly being spent
working on a new album now this is the
first time Taylor has posted anything
since May 3rd in fact the couple times
katie has returned to Instagram it's
been to promote her pal Haim and Lourdes
new music so if any of you had any
doubts whether Selena Higham and Lord
were still card-carrying members of the
squad there's your answer
now as for Selena she shared her new
song today fetish features gucci mane
and it's the second single off her still
untitled album following bad liar
that's the lyric video right there
featuring just her lips and it kind of
freaks me out
so I'm going to move on and Plus because
enough music it's time to talk to you v
the Emmy nominations were announced just
this morning so many great shows so many
nominees Saturday Night Live and
Westworld lead the pack with 22
nominations more than any other TV show
this year followed by stranger things
and feud that and jump still there are
some notable smells and surprises from
the list you might have missed so to
help me commiserate and celebrate please
welcome nominee for Outstanding Guest
Actress in the daily Jennie Lee and
Aguilera honored to be nominated
congratulation haha hi Jenny
hello you were out the nominations of
this morning I was I'm so tired I
believe that we're not talking about the
surprises on this list because for me
that is born from stranger things that
is right hashtag justice for barb has
been served
shannon for certain plays the beloved
stranger things character has earned her
very first Emmy nominations his Guest
Actress in a Drama Series and the
internet went crazy over this news I
don't really think anyone expected this
and the creator's the deaf brothers are
freaking out I think should be but I'm
thinking like are we in the upside down
because there is another major star who
was shut out completely for the lead
actress in a limited series category the
one and only Oprah what happen okay well
Oprah had some really stiff competition
in this category you know she starred in
The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks on
HBO and while she acted her space off
and she failed to score phenomena
against other a-list errors like a piggy
little eyes Reese Witherspoon and Nicole
Kidman or Jessica Lange and Susan
Sarandon from feud set and Jones so
Carol [ __ ] not just here so let me get
this straight
Oprah doesn't get an Emmy nomination
what Snoop Dogg does yes how fun is that
noop dog is nominated for outstanding
host of a reality competition series
along with his BFS miss Martha Stewart
for their reality show potluck dinner
party and he goes home rapper was
nominated this year chance the rapper
and comment both earned an on for
original music in America so it could be
a party at the end of yeah it's kind of
almost an actogram it's a little bit
okay so I know you caught up with
Chrissy Mets just moments after she was
nominated for this is us I mean I love
her I love Chrissy so much and she's got
love on the brain she told me that her
boyfriend Josh was even more nervous
than she was this morning waiting for
the nomination news and watch what
happens when I asked her whether or not
she's going to bring him to the Emmys
know that you're going to bring your mom
but can you bring two days I mean you
are a nominee can Josh make the cut - I
mean he could but but I thought I said
enough we had brought that for you and
excited we are set up we just made the
decision I mean that that's when it's
real when it pops by itself Wow I hope
nobody's things are damaged we had
breakfast for you to see it was right
over there and it was still with
everything on it you are amazing that
you've already you cute it like right
are you this is called Missy mad [ __ ]
about movie magic mm-hmm I get enough
cuz yeah yeah I don't I'm not really
worst on any alcoholic beverage
you got enough years she is my darling
thank you I appreciate it
that was awesome yeah just drinking with
Christine that's I mean it was great but
also like he kind of ruined the surprise
that champagne pop all right we got to
give a special shout out to another fan
favorite show
RuPaul's Drag Race ah earn seven
nominations if you're the most it's ever
received
and clean host RuPaul we love that show
so I'm really excited for them last
Queen Oh Leon Aguilera thank you so so
much for bringing down arms let me know
if I win this year okay I was I'm room
for yes bye girl are you guys can catch
more of me and actually tomorrow on the
daily Denny she's given us a preview of
season seven of Game of Thrones yes
winter is finally here folks and also
some exciting news for you guys we will
be live from Comic Con a week from today
that's right your boy is hitting the
road
cannot wait are you guys subscribe to e
t--'s youtube channel so you don't miss
that and of course stick with each
online for all the latest and
entertainment bye guys
happy any day Wow